Come to be a psychological test
We let the audience see the scene composed of eight shots.
The story is about suspicion and a little bit of confusion.
Let the audience go to the comments
A girl in his apartment has a suspicious unidentified man passing his window
She went out to figure out what was going on.
After the play, we asked the audience
Several open questions
Listen to their opinions
What do you feel? Like it?
Still don't like it? Problem like
We show the same movie to another group of viewers.
The only difference is
Each lens is left and right opposite
So the left-to-right motion has changed from right to left.
What we want to ask is, what does such an editor change?
Does the direction of the character affect the viewer's perception of the character?
Or does it affect the audience's perception of the whole show?
The answer is "will" and the impact is bigger than you think.
But why does walking direction affect it?
In order to understand the importance of direction change
We must understand the axes of the three movements
The characters on the screen can be moved in three directions.
Left and right, up and down, and before and after
The direction in which the character moves, which is associated with the scene.
Moving to the front of the camera shows his strength, dominance, and aggressiveness.
Far from the lens, it shows weakness
The same reasoning role looks down on behalf of the weak
Looking up, it looks high
"Now, my evil power will never stop!"
"Is it felt?"
"I feel that."
"呜~"
These two explanations have its truth
Of course, someone goes down and away from the lens
The angle of observation with someone up and close to the lens is different
[child scream]
[Monsters also start to scream]
But the last action moves laterally
Running from the right to the left is not so obvious.
What is the difference between the left and the right?
Why is it important from right to left?
The answer lies in "time" and "language"
In Western culture, from left to right symbolizes the direction of travel
Our language reading is also from left to right
Reading starts from the left and ends when we read to the right
In video games, the character starts on the left
The level ends on the right
Any line chart, go to the right time
In daily life, almost all towards the right
Symbolizes time, progress, normality
And the action to the left symbolizes going back to the past.
Symbolizes anomalies and degradation
This idea can be seen in the theory of film.
Left to right movements in the eyes of people
More natural and normal than right to left
Because our brain processes images naturally from left to right
Actions from left to right, symbolizing time and normal ideas are heavily used in movies
In a variety of movies
For example, "The Lord of the Rings" always keeps the action from left to right.
The journey from the Shire to the Doomsday volcano
All are left-right moving lenses
Using the screen to point out their goals without knowing it
Reach a specific location
Take the clear goal of "The Lord of the Rings" compared to the last scene of the "Golden Armor"
This scene consists of two shots
The first shot is the soldiers walking in front of the burned house, from left to right
The second shot is from right to left.
The background is still a burning house
Suddenly changing the side direction
Make people feel like they are changing direction at will
Implying that the soldiers are just arbitrarily arbitrarily aimless
Stanley Kubrick uses the direction of the direction to express his ideas
Point out that the military does not have a clear goal
Perhaps this is his comment on the entire Vietnam War.
The horizontal movement of the character can also tell the situation
In a scene of the "Golden Armor", the soldiers moved to the right
Moving toward the battle zone outside the picture
At the same time, the wounded soldier was brought back from the battle area.
From right to left
The reinforcements here suggest
Soldiers go to the place outside the screen
It is the place where the wounded soldier was carried back.
"King Khmer" and "Rescuing Rennes" also used the same lateral movement technique.
[background music, fuzzy conversation]
"Weide!" "Yes!"
"Look at what you can do?" "Report is"
So, from left to right, people feel positive and progressive, normal
At least that is the assumption of most film theorists.
It’s only about five years ago that this is the case.
Researchers began to move laterally from empirical surveys
In 2012, Cleveland State University did an experiment
By giving people a continuous shot of eight shots
They show the same movie to another group of people
But all left-to-right actions are changed from right to left.
Each group answers a few detailed questions
There are also some open questions like how they feel after reading.
The results confirm the hypothesis of many film theorists
But there is always no more reliable evidence to prove
The key to this experiment is to analyze the answers to open questions.
For example, 24.8% of people answered "anxiety", "tension", "uneasy" and "doubt"
Describe his feelings about the film
11.9% of people answered "fear", "fear" and "fright"
The biggest difference between the two groups is that
There is a discourse that the experimenter calls "negative influence"
Similar answers include "Don't like editing" "Like editing" "Feel good" "Feel bad" "Fun" "boring"
"Strong" and "weak" These are the answers to the two films.
Most different words
For the "left to right" film people always use like
"good", "fun", "strong" words
However, people who look from right to left will use words like "bad", "boring" and "cowardly".
The viewer’s view of the action from left to right is positive and vice versa.
This research is a great opportunity for filmmakers.
Simply change the direction of the character's movement
The director can instill negative or positive emotional reactions to the audience.
But it seems that some directors have already understood this technique.
Know from left to right, from right to left
Let's go back to the era of Hitchcock
The protagonist and villain of the "train geek" directed by Alfred Hitchcock
Just let us see the walking movements of their feet
They are close to each other, as if they would meet each other on the road that hints at the future.
If our research is right from left to right, it is more active than right to left.
This opening has already let us know in the subconscious.
Going from right to left, is the villain in the film
From left to right is the protagonist.
So the action from left to right is not just a symbol of the advancement of time.
Also suggesting whether something is positive or negative
Roger Ebert himself supports this argument.
As explained in his 2008 book How to Read a Movie
Roger Ebert even goes further to explain the left and right positions of the screen.
Give people a more positive feeling, or more negative
A character on the right makes people feel positive and controls the situation
At the same time, the character on the left will feel weak, maybe more evil.
This topic is also a commonplace. "Right - good, left - bad"
A lot of filmmakers use this technique
"The owner is my friend."
"You do not have friends"
"Hey! You go away!"
"You just walk away!"
"You!" "You are!"
"you!"
"Reverse is going to thunder!"
"AhRRRRRR!"
Roger Ebert claims that this technique of left and right position
Has transcended language and culture and is used everywhere
He said all the movies he has seen in his life.
Asian film will use similar left and right matchup skills
And the findings support his arguments.
Regional beliefs, right and left habits, and ethnicity
Will not affect the viewer's feeling of moving laterally
Of course, making a movie is not absolute.
And sometimes, the opposite rule can get the same effect.
But either way, the research shows the results
There is a difference between the left or right side of the movie.
Because it is the theory of recent years, the experience of using film skills can also confirm
Roger Ebert said he once suspected himself when he convinced himself.
But now it has been confirmed
I contacted Cleveland State University.
Ask the person who did the research at the beginning
They still continue to do research
Test film theory
After 100 years, I can learn new film making skills.
I feel very excited
Previous suspicions, there is now clear evidence
So, the next time you see the character crossing the screen. Think carefully:
"Where did he go?"
"Which direction does he go?"
"Where did he go?" "Where did he go?"
"I don't know. He took my clothes and went over there."
"Fast chase"
Thank you for watching, I have to clarify the experimental film at the beginning.
Not the film originally studied
That movie is not public
But they have articles that make movies publicly.
So I copied the film according to the narrative of the article.
I highly recommend that research article.
Really great! I thoroughly discussed this topic and it was something I never thought about before.
I will put the link in the video information.
In addition, the film theorist I mentioned in the film
No name
In fact, I am referring to "Levy Coules"
He is super fierce and writes a bunch of film theory
In the 1970s, he proposed three axes of film action.
And how do people think about the action in the movie?
Recommend you GOOGE for him.
I will also put some of his works on the film information (translation: harureya)
Thank you (translation: harureya)